[Music]
In Source Ark My son also uses
S-Mac after his body Sentry Scott Click n
Team n Vem Unique Braque Liz
Release 2 So almost with you
[Music]
Uh hello I'm noona What are you uh I
'm a musician who plays the gayageum
[Music
] Uh go  He
's one of the Korean traditional folks. It's a
very old and
influencing tradition in our country, but it
's not.
The date knows eye eye la
route
it easier
The songs I cover are mainly rock
music And the label extension with the
drug seems to fit me well.
Peppers
[Music]
I'm a musician who started out on YouTube
* Finally a new version ws my hand loo
won grave 2
ah ah noona bone and 4p 5p infancy uh
this
is the first time I got to know gayageum through me
I
heard gayageum playing for the first time and then
Korean traditional musical instruments and traditions I think I
get to know about the traditional
culture naturally.
Oh and elk as a result I think I've
found my music this past now I'm so
surprised
[Music]
co ah